China and Russia the two countries say
their friendship has no limits but is
that still the case what's driving it
and what's the cost
to understand the china-russia
Friendship better we've come to the city
of Hai it is a write-up in the very
north of China on the border with Russia
over this Frozen River that's Russia
itself and there are signs everywhere in
this place of just how vital the
relationship is to both sides there is a
huge Bridge up ahead that takes trade to
and from the two countries there is a
lot of crossover of culture there is a
lot in this town that explains why the
countries are such good friends
foreign
if you look back over history China and
Russia haven't always been allies there
was periods of conflict along this
border and although China looked at
Russia for inspiration to set up its
communist system there were long periods
of deep distrust but the two countries
are getting closer at the moment and
there's a number of reasons for that
firstly they do a lot of trade with each
other important trade in Commodities
secondly it's very important for both
sides to keep this northern border
peaceful it means both of them can
redirect resources elsewhere but most
importantly at the moment it's that
they're like-minded allies in what both
of them see as an increasing power
struggle with the West president XI and
President Putin have a lot in common
they both believe that autocracy is the
best way to run a country they both have
bitter and deep dislike for what they
see as american-led interference in the
world and they both want to see a new
world order with their ideas and their
systems at the fore foreign
opinions of Ordinary People vary it's
important to know that here in China
people are not told the truth about
what's happening in the war in Ukraine
news content on the war is very
sanitized and very straight it means
that a lot of people here particularly
in towns like this really support the
Russians they see them as a good friend
and a good Ally
and what do you think of the conflict in
Ukraine
but there are some people in China who
hold skepticism too largely because of
that very distrustful and often very
difficult historic relationship with
Russia distrust here also exists
[Music]
in terms of the war in Ukraine China is
positioning itself as a peacemaker it
says it's one of the few countries in
the world that hasn't sold arms to
either side and that has good relations
with both and that could posture for
peace it is the reason that she is
meeting both Putin and speaking to
president zielinski in the same week
people in the west say those claims
though ring Hollow the Americans have
accused China of preparing to sell arms
Acclaim the Chinese absolutely reject
but the Chinese do have an interest in
ensuring that this war does not result
in a very United and very Victorious
West and the reason for that is that if
and when it wanted to make its own move
perhaps invading the self-governing
island of Taiwan it wants forces like
America and NATO to be delegitimized
it means that the world is grappling
with two powers that because of their
relationship with each other have the
confidence to continue to be assertive
and in Russia's case quite aggressive on
the foreign stage for now this
relationship is likely to last because
both sides are gaining more from it than
what they would gain if it fell apart
how China in particular chooses to use
this relationship is yet to be seen but
for the moment the trade the diplomacy
and the peaceful water is very important
to both sides